aloha reject nation I'm Greg Alba John
Humphrey
we're gonna watch top ten box office
bombs that ruin Studios from
watchmojo.com topper war to your request
from a man named Cameron French over on
a pitch around whatever video you're
requesting was definitely doing put up
on the YouTube channel and today comes
from that good man let's roll into this
hey they can't all be hits right welcome
to watchmojo.com picks for the top 10
movies that bombed is so hard they
bankrupted studios before we begin we
pull and wring them out to get notified
about our latest videos for this list
we're taking a look at box-office qualms
and disappointments that caused a movie
studio to go bankrupt taking into
account their critical reception we're
using the term bankrupt and loose water
meaning that the films in question don't
need to have officially filed for
bankruptcy instead they could have
significantly hurt their Studios
financially caused a sale or merger and
or cause them to shut down to put it
simply these flicks severely crippled
their respective production or
distribution studios number 10 super or
the quest for peace the Canon Group
Incorporated in Canon the end of
Superman after three mostly solid
incremental series the characters rights
were sold to Cannon Films a company with
a history of financial woes Superman for
the quest for peace was intended to have
a budget of 36 million dollars but that
was soon reduced to 17 million dollars
and even then it still failed to recoup
its debts rift eNOS was apparent on
screen in spades from a visible lack of
production values a weak story and
script and a horribly lame
and it dissuaded fans and critics alike
worsening the studio's already strained
financial situation the follow-up facing
bankruptcy saw Canon change hence when
it was taken over by path a
communications
despite varied efforts to pay off its
debts reorganize the company and switch
execs it ultimately closed up shop in
1994 strand of his hair to the museum
number nine raise the Titanic associated
film distribution ITC entertainment
raise the Titanic appeared poised for
box-office success
unfortunately not how things played out
they said good NSYNC film made back just
seven million dollars of its 40 million
dollar budget which producer Liu grade
quipping quote it would have been
cheaper to lower the Atlantic some claim
that the author Clive Cussler is public
dismissal of the film based on his novel
of the same name was partially
responsible for its port reception this
along with a poorly timed film about the
Village People set in motion the series
of events that would lead to associated
film distribution the British film
distribution company that ITC
entertainments set up to distribute
their movies in the u.s. to be sold to
Universal Pictures in the early 80s
despite continuing to produce content
ITC itself became defunct in 1998 number
8 astro boy imagi animation studios
after making waves with TMNT they are
animated Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
film Imagi to do x' were ready to take
the next step in becoming major
hollywood players
unfortunately that next step turned into
one of the biggest cinematic
disappointments of the decade astro boy
i thought i found it but I guess vidiian
can be a lot more complicated than it
seems huh good boy the movie flopped
hard at the box office
there's 42 million dollars of it's sixty
five million dollar budget astroboy
wound up being the final film produced
by imagi animation studios which one
under in 2010 leaving a short list of
uncompleted and abandoned projects in
its wake
number seven It's a Wonderful Life Oh
woody films
it's a Christmas classic now that's a
Wonderful Life was actually a box office
dead this is in part because although it
was released just in time for Christmas
on December 20th not like a white house
it didn't actually release until January
7th in 1947 a day by which most people
are pretty well Christmas doubt I guess
I'm not quite the football type oh yeah
you you look wonderful you know if it
wasn't me talking I tell you were there
prettiest girl in town barely earning
back its three point eighteen million
dollar budget
the film's poor reception left his
production company at Liberty films
unable to recoup costs on the verge of
bank foreclosures yesterday he knew
ownership while they found it in
Paramount Pictures in May 1947 which
made It's a Wonderful Life the only film
the company released independently under
paramount ownership Liberty would
release only one other film State of the
Union before closing in 1951 triple x--
number six Heaven's Gate is retarted it
was highly anticipated and that's just
what led to its failure oh yeah Harrison
around for a long time second film as a
direction Camino became a double Academy
Award winner and it was granted this
movie is a home so many eyes it was
bullets against each other what are you
crazy
this resulted in a film that was well
behind schedule over budget and ripe
with allegations of animal abuse and
curatorial megalomania once completed
the project had a runtime of nearly five
and a half hours eventually trimmed down
to three hours and 39 minutes
however audiences did not show and the
box office cake was a mere 3.5 million
on a 44 million dollar budget this
prompted the sale of United Artists to
MGM studios shortly thereafter
number five final fantasy the spirits
within square pictures in 2001 square
pictures the film leg of Japanese video
game company square decided to give
final fantasy a big-screen adaptation
the result was the one to see the
spirits within the film featured the
voice work of Alec Baldwin and Donald
Sutherland and drew considerable praise
for its photorealistic enemies it's
pretty great still fails though with a
broad audience taking in only a
worldwide gross of 85 million dollars
that's your plan we wait and see what
happens yes in fact the under
performance was so great it was enough
to significantly delay a merger
involving the studio's parent company
with Enix fortunate Sony Corp provided
square with some capital and they recoup
some of the financial losses thanks to
video game sales after the merger went
through only Enix survived with square
pictures becoming a consolidated
subsidiary of Square Enix and Square co
limited dissolving Jane do you mind if
we stop talking I'm trying to
concentrate here
number 4 where's Katie Fox Animation
Studios see the Titan was truly position
Fox animation then ship in the I have
owned this movie in my whole life and
never seen
on paper Titan 80 seem to have hit
potential and and it featured an
all-star cast including Matt Damon Bill
Pullman and Drew Barrymore Fox Animation
Studios look to be on a roll one that
would hopefully allow them to compete
with the likes of Disney and DreamWorks
however Titan a Eve massive budget
convoluted plot and unclear demographic
led it to being a massive box office
bomb yeah well who's to say it would
have worked anyway
Fox Animation Studios had been in
trouble for some time like hail hundreds
of employees the year before
unfortunately Titan 80 pushed them off
the cliff and a little over a week after
its release the company shut down let me
live provided I kill all of you before
they get to me it's been smooth sailing
for Fox ever since the beat up number
three the Golden Compass was this new
Line Cinema's last movie I had hoped to
recreate a tremendous financial success
of The Lord of the Rings film series
when they put the Golden Compass into
production adapted from a popular line
of young adult books the film boasted a
budget of 180 million dollars making it
one of the most expensive films of the
year by the numbers this gamble paid off
as the film grossed 372 million dollars
worldwide however that 180 million
dollar budget was funded by the sale of
the film's international rights with
only the 70 million dollar domestic take
going back to new line this failure is
seen by most as the moment that forced
the studio's hand into merging with
Warner Brothers meaning that to be a
studio that was separately operated as I
was like I have to see their name all
the time cutthroat island
Kuroko pictures I knew you'd wind up
here at some point that beamed the
cheese and you being the rat
thing is Ben I'm basically a shot man
you know you've made a horrible mistake
when you file for bankruptcy before your
movie hit theaters Elko Pictures which
filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy
protection a month out of the release of
1995's cutthroat island intended to be
the studio's comeback the movie was not
only light on star power but was also
funded by the sale of multiple films
including Stargate which not only fared
significantly better but spawned a
massive television franchise cutthroat
island meanwhile made just ten million
dollars against its 98 million dollars
hahaha my slave is found at Rhode Island
before we unveil our top pick here are
some dishonorable mentions people kill
cops that's a circle life
Hakuna Matata I'm glad to see you
Hustler's wasn't ahead STX entertainment
be on this list
I think I just figured it out number one
Battlefield Earth franchise pictures
especially now coded worst picture of
the decade in 2010 and winner of eight
Golden Raspberry Awards Battlefield
Earth is one of the first movies that
comes to mind when you hear the words
box office disaster based on a novel by
Scientology founder l ron hubbard the
film was a longtime passion project for
star and noted Scientologist John
Travolta despite being turned down by
almost every studio in Hollywood
Travolta finally found a backer in
franchise pictures however the
combination of a poor box off his return
and the fallout from legal issues
surrounding the
by which the film was financed or
franchise pictures to file for
bankruptcy in 2007 do you agree with our
picks
check out these so many Dutch angles to
be notified about our latest videos I
mean the makeup and Battlefield Earth
look pretty cool I'd be curious to see
WatchMojo put together a list of studios
that have high probability of going out
of business
hair mounts are really pulling teeth
lately their mounts struggling a lot
like they're really honing in on their
mission impossible franchise but it's
their fridge not been doing too hot all
around it's crazy when these like
juggernauts of movie studios start going
under the sea one corrala co carla co
they produce Terminator 2 really yeah I
always remember every time I see that
logo I think a terminator - ha ha the
sea forming so I have a nostalgia for it
but I don't know what happened to that
company sometimes these Studios you
think are dead and then their logo
suddenly appears again it's like
whenever I see a Dimension Films logo of
like things get absorbed and turned into
labels instead for other bigger
companies or like how Orion Pictures has
been coming back around again lately now
you see new line with the Warner Media
underneath yeah and I always see Orion
pictures with like Robocop or something
and like we saw child's playing at Orion
Pictures though like oh I forget about
these guys by Karluk Oh like yeah they
had Stargate in the same year they did
showgirl in cutthroat island so that
helped make sense why they went down
because they were hot man they had the
Universal Soldier they had cliffhanger
they did a lot of big it's there's a lot
of big movies they did especially in the
90s it's so easy to look at like the
box-office bombs but this is a
fascinating list to think about Studios
that went out I never could remember
which studio produced Titan a he I was
like oh there's a fox animation movie
studio yeah the second they brought that
name up it was like a brick I was like
oh yeah I remember Fox animation used to
exist funny enough I never did see Titan
AE and that's probably when I forgot
that Fox Anna
yeah and weirdly that was the one movie
out of this list perhaps that watching
the footage made me want to go back and
check it out because the rest of these
kind of looked like you could tell why
they were flubs yeah that's that's fair
I mean United Artists I used to see
their logo a lot like they pretty some
Bond films to remember Tomorrow Never
Dies or they like merged with MGM or
something like that
I mean MGM has had famous struggles as a
student the thing that's fascinating
about this is you start to realize why
the studio's cling so heavily to these
major franchise events because like you
pointed out paramount now kind of can
only rely on mission impossible and for
a while MGM could only rely on James
Bond and now it seems as though they've
they've merged
yeah United Artists has merged with MGM
because like they're producing no time
to die so oh man this is wildly
confusing yeah this is why everything
just should be under Disney keep track
of that monopolies man I'm telling you
like I was here about studio wars and
all these things and I'm always like
wait what who who belongs where even
studios get confused with each other man
I remember that the trailer for like the
gallows two came out and I put the sad
heart community page because I just
thought it was so funny whatever company
that is co-producing with Blum House was
it Lionsgate yeah Blum House put out the
trailer on their channel you know
because they made the movie and then I
went to watch the trailer and then it
said this video is blocked by Lionsgate
how do the right ground yeah copyright
your ads and I'm like you guys producers
together didn't yeah this is idiotic
you're literally robbing yourself of
every Tyson Zab really the craziest one
to me is It's a Wonderful Life yeah I
haven't heard of half of these movies
the other half I'm like yeah that are
known to be disasters but there's only
one movie here that is considered a
classic yeah that's considered of great
Phil one of my favorite film that's is a
yearly watch for a lot of family
households yeah I heard that it wasn't a
success and it came out and I also heard
that it wasn't originally a Christmas
movie and then they sort of tweaked
their marketing to make it like a
Christmas movie it's not hard to believe
that if you watch the actual movie
there's Christmas in it yeah yeah
business really like the last 20 minutes
that
it's a Christmas movie yeah really the
most of his The Pursuit of Happyness
pretty much so yeah and I mean there's
also that point they brought up about
that movie which I thought was
interesting where it wasn't necessarily
that the project went awry or you a
Taman a mininum megalomaniacal director
or anything like that it was just yeah
people were Christmas doubt and they
released this in early January so maybe
it just kind of landed with a thud and
nobody really was into it at the time
and it's also you know kind of a heavy
emotional movie for that time of years
yeah so it's just thing like even timing
yeah can really hurt that's true that's
true
I'm fascinated by Renny Harlin's career
because the only movie I was pretty
certain would have to be on this list
was cutthroat island because I've just
yeah that's that movie's legacy is just
being a disastrous bomb and the thing is
like I feel like that follows Renny
Harlin around because that dude still
works and I feel like those are the
projects he seems to get are things that
have perhaps a riskily big-budget that
tend to flop hard
that's unfortunate man yeah going back
to New Line Cinema like the Golden
Compass was very much hated on but now
that art isn't in the show now for HBO I
think what the other Warner Brothers is
partnered up with now yeah his Dark
Materials right is there the same world
of Lord because I've always heard this
name kept in the cultural lexicon
because of its sister properties and the
fact that yeah his material is coming
it's funny for franchise pitchers to
complic sometimes you give yourself such
a bold title for a production company
and you just go right under which is
embarrassing bold title or or I'd notice
very genera there are a couple of these
companies that were just like associated
distribution sounds like the most
generic but yeah for especially for
Battlefield Earth which could have had
franchise potential if they had nailed
them it's weird sometimes you think
these movie studios have like infinite
amounts of money because they're movies
yes and then you hear them go under it
like so many of these movies I didn't
even know who this studios were that
made these movies and then it seems like
in the cultural zeitgeist of things that
now we're more aware than ever
especially if it's under the
the umbrella or Fox umbrella all that
talk about Fox it's kind of crazy to me
never since the Disney Fox murder
happened all the Fox related films have
not been doing well like none of them
it's pretty gnarly how bad it's been and
like they bought it and so there's a big
deal because we're like we finally get
Deadpool and Wolverine and fantastic
horny and everything else and everything
like Ford V Ferrari supposed to be
coming out this month it's good and that
was like a hundred million dollar
production budget I'm like that movie's
gonna make that much money back because
they are marketing that bad boy a lot
well that's the thing that I kept
thinking about throughout this list too
and they broke my heart for the Golden
Compass was that like it technically
kind of made its money back but
especially with what we know we know so
much more about advertising now that
it's like nowhere near the amount oh
yeah it would have needed to make to
truly clear a profit well would foreign
sales to like a lot of movies the
franchise especially Terminator included
are able to stay alive because of
foreign distribution but in terms of the
states making that money back they get
like a most 50% of the foreign sales
usually is less so movie account here
has to be the most complicated field day
fascinating list
yes fascinating list I can't wait for
Paramount to be included on here soon
it's just gonna be testing in Warner's
after a while we hear stories like this
and then you know why Studios want more
franchising but I think I think we're
probably also in a day and age where we
have streaming I think there's gonna be
a lot more partnerships happening with
movie studios as well well that's
something yeah I mean that's something
you've seen I was always surprised to
see through TV the studio collaborations
happen a lot in the TV space because
everyone's sharing sound stages and
productions and if Fox might not run
their own show on their own network you
know but I feel like too with the
streaming now everybody's bringing their
content direct to you so I feel like the
presence of a studio is gonna be
something different moving forward now
that you have Disney Plus and Warner's
is gonna have their own thing and
there's HBO Max and there's HBO Max and
there
their own production company as well as
the network that runs a whole bunch of
other movies yeah so yeah with
everything happening it's gonna be
fascinating to see house because the
studios are now gonna be relying heavily
on their streaming services on top of
that too there's a discussion of the
original films of those streaming
services are gonna be producing now
which films normally would they have put
in the theatres yeah are now gonna just
be going directly to their streaming
services and will they do that with any
of their franchise properties like well
they make sequels that go directly to
HBO max or Disney Plus or something like
that and all asset is the one thing you
got to give a weird kind of credit to or
let some treating suit and something
like would Disney and then what they did
with spider-man and Sony because of the
global conglomerate that those franchise
properties are and then wanting
characters to cross over it's made a lot
of us learn a lot more about franchise
dealing contracts tribute having a
better understanding of why people hold
on to these IPs and such and why they
milk them the way they like of course a
lot of us I've always sort of followed
it but then there's I think more and
more people invested in the conversation
of studios and streaming and all these
things and I think it was around the
time of understanding the way these
deals work of wiring all these Marvel
characters over here yeah I think it
really started linking up in people's
minds to try to understand this around
them maybe spider-man's to thank that
merger and then also getting the beta
the ability to share these characters
has caused a lot of us to like learn a
lot more about these things so I think a
few years ago this this conversation
would've been like oh that's interesting
now it's like oh this makes now you can
that be added on top of it you could see
how this all came to be yeah you can see
the ecosystem so much better where the
ripples are and what it means for the
bigger picture whereas before you might
have just gone Oh
interestingly unfortunate
yeah it's like that thing of yeah I do I
want more original films absolutely but
then you hear about this where you're
like oh that's right I used to see those
logos all the time maybe a movie I loved
helped put them there yeah because if
you look at this list some of them are
IPS you know based off of like fantasies
of games like movie actually like I
contributed to the box-office
so like that had a built in an audience
Golden Compass included but the only one
of these that has a sequel that tanked a
studio was Superman oh it even shows
there that like a sequel can tank his
duty to the biggest game at a time yeah
all right guys well this was fun
anything they left office listed you'd
like to talk about let us know you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects and
click that notification medley and
notify whenever got a youtube video up
sir Cameron French Wiebe I wanted to say
to you buddy that the amount of times
that we have been talking I want to
encourage you to start your own movie
blog dude I think you should get it
going I don't know what your voice
sounds like you refuse to speak with us
over the phone I've given you my phone
number just been waiting by they're
going when's he gonna call me you won't
call me you won't FaceTime me you won't
Skype but your opinions I think are
really well laid out
you're quite thoughtful and you often
state things that make me go huh never
saw it that way so I think you should
start up a blog dude that's where I'm
going here this I got a name for it film
French French films French films and you
only talk about an American